[Music]
a south florida influencer who
is refusing
to apologize
for posing for instagram pictures in
front of her late father's court oh that
she did a selfie oh yeah she's making
her apologize she did a uh she did a
[ __ ] she used it to for clout for
instagram clout i mean she's taking pics
is how she what she did was one of the
pictures her on her knees and then like
this
that was one of her pictures
you're close
like one of her pictures like she's
older what is this like this
you both are close
uh you both actually nailed a pose
are you ready
i think you got to press it with the
mouse now
cool thanks
cool awesome cool i left it sick sick
sick volume sick yeah oh prayer hands
she did all of them
wow she um need to bring hands
she got those like eva mendez evil eyes
that are kind of hot
i agree
why is she having a sex sexy photo shoot
in front of a casket
that's what she does
oh that's the ca i didn't even realize
that
she was like she's like i don't think i
should apologize i want to hear her like
voice because then that'll determine
whether or not i'm like for her or not
you know what i mean who saw them on it
depends on how she talks that makes
sense
she makes a good point already shut down
her account
he's checked and my instagram says
instagram disabled
a spokesperson for instagram says the
account was removed for violating
without her dad
not for the photos rivera says she did
nothing wrong and has the right to
grieve her father however she wants it's
still my dad that's my i'm gonna do a
photo shoot with my daddy i can post
he wouldn't be mad my dad would not be
mad i think my dad is looking down
rooting me on saying that's my girl in
fort lauderdale can win but you blocked
them
like it's just a casket like what do you
mean pictures with my dad like i don't
even see them in the coffin i mean it's
kind of tasteful if you had to if you
hadn't take pictures like i'm taking a
picture with anthony dog
you know like if you had to take
pictures with the casket i don't think
you could have done it more tastefully
frankly she should have done a [ __ ]
photo shoot like this she should have
done this though she should have done
like the
yeah
she didn't do one and she should have
she should have done duck lips for sure
no it's one of their go-to's anyway i
wonder if her caption was offensive too
what did it say it said namaste
really one of them said namaste no well
the instagram said they didn't even name
a blocker for that they blocked it for
something else right uh yeah they they
said that it it violated the terms or
whatever the [ __ ] yeah she
oh it wasn't for just his violating
rules not for the photos
i guess if i were to be objective and
fair i'd be like she totally deserves
any of the like whatever she got from
being a social figure and doing that and
if people like were like upset or like
this is weird then i think she deserves
that just as much as i think she
deserves the ability to be like it's my
dad i can do what i want and then
everybody has to shut up it's an open
platform it's like putting art up goes
sucks and some people like i like this
art yeah we all signed up for it like
the comments are open place you can say
whatever the [ __ ] you want so now we
have to figure out what would be
acceptable for her to take pictures with
her dead father what would it be what
poses she should have been more naked i
think if she was in a negligee it's
wait oh what is that it's florida it's
it's hot why are you wearing clothes
it's what um i don't know it's only my
vocab because kat was sitting here and
she said she she posted pictures in her
necklace right now and i'm like okay
that's in my tree now i don't even know
what that looks like i've always wanted
to know what that means clothing it's
like a it's a good night you think yeah
yeah laundry is it i'm just assuming god
damn it i have to look up niggles yet
god how do you spell that that's the
thing is that like evening lingerie yeah
i think so as opposed to like
morning long day day walker laundry a
day walker it's very french oh sounds
very french you know what i'm saying i
like that
okay
all right here we go that's a negligee
sirs
oh those
that's just a see-through dress oh got
it it's a secret it's an idea it's
something it's an extra layer to take a
curtain it's for the night yeah that's
cool that's fun see through curtains i
enjoy those it's like i say keep it on
just lift it up it's when you turn four
play into like five play you don't
understand down what do you guys think
of bras where the the boobs are already
out in them hell yeah cupless bras i
disagree with it funny will you say that
again you know why cuz it lifts it up no
i know it lifts it up but i just
disagree with the fundamentally it
leaves nothing to the mystery well what
about the ones with the pasties that are
right in the middle that like you show
all the skin around and yeah
you like to say with the tassels so when
they [ __ ] shirt in [ __ ] circles
like that
oh yeah
trashy [ __ ] but not to where it's like
her tits are all the way out already
yeah yeah oh you like the peekaboo
i love it you want to open the door yes
right when the under shows oh
yeah
it's underrated
i think so yeah yeah that's like the new
cleavage huh undertake for sure it's
better than [ __ ] side boop to me for
sure cyboop is nice but yeah that's good
that's not going to say
[Laughter]
cleavage is like
butt cheeks on the chest yeah but crack
on a chestnut i've heard a lot of people
say that with a little bit less feces
but yeah
a little bit
i hope it's clean
it's a little disturbing how well lined
up your head is to this body by the way
it's like you gotta [ __ ] the a [ __ ] the
cook apron on
if you if you could do us a favor and
actually because we see some of her chin
and lip if you could buy perspective
push yourself back and then show us less
of your a little lower a little lower
you're still on my head
yeah yeah yeah or just or just would you
guys [ __ ] with me
i would definitely thank you i [ __ ]
the top half of you thank you guys yeah
only because of the tarot oh wow
so i mean back to this girl who was
getting a lot of hate for [ __ ] posing
in front of her hilarious dude me my dad
we always had this relationship like i
was always [ __ ] holding out in front
of him what are you guys talking about
he took all my hoping
that's the thing some people just have
their [ __ ]
but then yeah you have to take the
scrutiny remember when hulk hogan was
getting some [ __ ] for [ __ ] putting
suntan lotion on his daughter
saying that that [ __ ] is so weird how
old was his daughter bro she was like
she was she's full grown she's full
grown this after hogan knows best yeah
yeah but they act like they were he was
like on her ass like [ __ ] doing one
of these numbers like he was putting
lotion on like a dad would on a daughter
you know like he wasn't like [ __ ]
doing one of these things yeah but he
was putting on her butt guys
really oh yeah oh yeah
let me show you hold on hold on
do you think the butt is weird but if
he's like no let me apply it for you i
believe i belie i'll do this so
pixelated looks like [ __ ] and even if
she asked him to do it on her butt
specifically that's also sus that's
weird that's a little bit weird it's us
if i was a dad i'd be like find somebody
else to put it on
that's what i would say i'd be like
hogan knows best yeah that's what i find
some random things
it's not even sexualized for me but when
it's family even if it's ass yeah it's
just the body part you just go
i mean if you fight it that way good but
i don't know if you cannot do that he
did not do it like that effective way
though
yeah like that's just one of these
things man no one's doing it like he
doesn't have a bunch of hand prints
everywhere what if you know what if you
know the press is filming you at that
moment
you start buying you do it any
differently than you normally would if
the press is [ __ ] filming
i'll look i'll look directly in their
eye and i'm going to dude
that's funny i'm okay with that if you
really look at the press through the
press
all right here you go
all right it's the angle dude
my whole thing is she can't put
sunscreen on her thigh you can't hit i
don't have to go back
you can't do this brook hogan
think about being a chick though you
have small arms
very short yeah that's right that's
right or maybe she's on a really
important call or text messages
maybe she thinks it's her mom doing it
it does look like he's about the credit
card or a little bit
hey
right at the end of this real quick it
should be illegal i think
that's illegal see here we go
i do think though it's like maybe if
you're not famous it's like i can
understand why that shouldn't be a
problem but when you are famous you
enter a world of new
rules oh yeah it's like people would if
what if it was his son
then would that be inappropriate that
would be large if his son was wearing
that outfit i don't know
i think no son do put
sunscreen lotion
on your thigh yourself if it was your
upper middle back i got you always and
that goes for every one of you guys next
time you go to the beach and you guys
need i'm gonna need help in my inner
thigh bro do that that's the only zone
if she's like dad my [ __ ] keeps getting
burned
then it's okay it's okay because full
disclosure
is my issue with this that's pretty
intimate i'm not going to she can't do
that herself
that's who's backhanding credit cardio
he's he's putting it on the back of his
hand and then he's he's using his
fingernails only he's like terry still
looks good though huh oh yeah he's here
he knows he's terry hogan dude terry
boleta dude well leia that's his real
name
is it oh okay come on alex
like [ __ ] [ __ ] well colgan dude i
know stone cold steve austin yeah what's
his full name all american hero stone
cold steve patrick austin
his amateur hour
i thought stone cold was actually the
owner of coldstone
that would have been a great integration
having him advertised for coldstone
would have been lit right that would
have made so much sense either that were
mr clean yeah
right i always thought he could have
done paul could have done mr clean i
think i guess so yeah he coded too he
also could have been the slim jim guy
for all we know i'm talking about the
macho man yeah i know but you know what
i'm saying randy savage yeah but i'm
just saying like could it be him too
more than him it was between those two
guys i think yeah you remember when um
macho man showed up in spider-man and
he's like it's me boom saul yeah yeah
yeah yeah
with that same face too
but he's in the cave
when he's fighting for like the money to
get the money
the toby one yeah yeah yeah
that was yeah
i like him in ready to rumble too you're
messing with the macho man
the best
the macho man
oh yeah but he was uh bone saw mcgraw
girl
that's a good name dude
mcgraw bone he actually died which is
crazy because yeah
i mean this guy's a [ __ ] legend dude
he's like purple his blood pressure and
all that [ __ ] is probably so high in
this picture he passed away when he was
like 55 or something yeah
young
a lot of steroid guys diet in their 50s
huh i just i know somebody that just
passed away he's like 31. oh my god
31 bro jack but i mean he was on a lot
of stuff yeah you get a big heart from
steroids right because it grows but what
a lot of these people don't pay
attention to is like like their
cholesterol their blood pressure they
don't pay attention to that so let's do
this and all that [ __ ] will rise up and
it's just
that's why every year when i watch the
grinch i'm just kind of [ __ ] up he's
getting a large heart that's
not good for him he's promoting that but
it was three sizes too small already
but dude
it was working for his body you know
you